I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody, it's a Monday. We are slipping into your feed early this week because after this, we are going to go
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》。大家好，今天是星期一。我们本周会提前登陆你们的节目动态，因为在此之后，我们打算去
on a vacay. Vacation. My birthday's coming up. It's summer. We're going to go spend some time with our families. That's right. We'll be back on July 13th with Secretary's Day with special guest Ellie Kemper. Oh, it's so fun.
度个假。度假。我的生日快到了。这是夏天。我们要去花点时间陪陪家人。没错。我们将在7月13日带着特别嘉宾艾莉·肯珀回归，那一期是“秘书日”。哦，太有趣了。
But today, we're going to talk to you all about happy hour. It is Season 6, Episode 21, written by BJ Novak, directed by Matt Zone. Would you like a summery? Boy, would I. Oscar organizes a happy hour for everyone in The Office as an excuse to spend time with Matt from the warehouse. Pam invites a friend to the bar as a kind of setup for Michael because what is she thinking? Pam, Pam, Pam, Pam.
但今天，我们要和大家聊聊欢乐时光。这是第六季第二十一集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，马特·佐恩执导。你想要一个总结吗？我太想听了。奥斯卡为办公室里的每个人组织了一场欢乐时光，以此为借口和仓库的马特共度时光。帕姆邀请了一位朋友去酒吧，作为给迈克尔的一场变相相亲，因为她在想什么呢？帕姆，帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。
But the setup is foiled by Michael's alter ego, Date Mike. Meanwhile, Andy and Erin are trying to keep their dating life a secret to avoid any drama that might come from openly dating a fellow co-worker, but in the end, Andy has a pretty fantastic grand announcement. He does. And one thing to add to your summary, Angela's going to debut some bright red lipstick. I noticed that, and I was hoping you were going to talk about it. Oh, I will.
但这场相亲被迈克尔的分裂人格——约会迈克给搅黄了。与此同时，安迪和艾琳正试图对他们的恋情保密，以避免公开与同事交往可能带来的任何戏剧性事件，但最终，安迪发表了一个非常精彩的重大宣告。确实如此。还要在你的总结中补充一点，安吉拉将首次涂上鲜红色的口红。我注意到了，我正希望你谈谈呢。哦，我会的。
Fast fact number one, this episode was directed by our camera operator Matt Zone. This was the first episode of The Office that he directed. He's directed many more. We've talked about him a lot, yes, because he's an amazing, awesome person. We were so excited for him to direct. Yeah, well, he said we were very supportive, but he also said we gave him a little shit throughout the week. Well, it's because we had all become such close friends.
第一条快速事实，这一集由我们的摄像师马特·佐恩执导。这是马特·佐恩执导的第一集《办公室》。他后来执导了更多集。我们经常谈论他，是的，因为他是一个了不起、极好的人。我们为他能执导感到非常兴奋。是的，嗯，他说我们非常支持他，但他也说我们在这一周里给他找了不少麻烦。嗯，那是因为我们都已经成了非常亲密的朋友。
It's true. So we messed with him a little bit, but it was like the way you tease someone you love. Well, as you can tell, I reached out to Matt. He shared some of his memories of directing, but he also gave us some shit because we've not had him on the podcast. Oh, he threw us some shade. I want to point out my memory is that Rain gave him the most shit. On set?
确实如此。所以我们有点捉弄他，但这就像你逗弄你爱的人的方式一样。嗯，正如你所知，我联系了马特。他分享了他的一些导演回忆，但也给我们找了点麻烦，因为我们没有邀请他上过播客。哦，他有点阴阳怪气我们。我想指出我的记忆是雷恩给他找的麻烦最多。在片场？
Yeah. You might be right. Mm-hmm. I mean, that tracks. Right. I told Matt I was kind of shocked that he hasn't been on the podcast because I feel like we talk about him all the time. I mean, he's the one who gets all of the background glances and everything.
是的。你可能是对的。嗯。我是说，这很合理。没错。我告诉马特，我有点震惊他没有上过播客，因为我觉得我们一直在谈论他。我是说，他就是那个捕捉到所有背景眼神等等的人。
He's the reason half of accounting stuff makes it in. Well, here's what Matt had to say. He said that Randall Einhorn was the cinematographer for this episode, and that made everything a lot easier because he and Randall both operated the cameras for years. They had worked together a long, long time. He said he had the advantage of knowing the material very well, knowing the world very well. He felt like he had everyone's trust, so he didn't have to do a lot of catch up or make
他就是会计部门的一半镜头能播出的原因。嗯，马特是这么说的。他说伦纳德·爱因霍恩是这一集的摄影指导，这让一切变得容易得多，因为他和伦纳德两人操作摄像机多年。他们合作了很长很长时间。他说他有很熟悉素材、很熟悉这个世界的优势。他觉得大家都信任他，所以他不需要做很多赶进度或做
any introductions. And then he also sent in this audio clip about what it meant to him to get to direct this episode. I was a camera operator on the show since season one, and was very fortunate that Greg Daniels gave me the opportunity to direct my first episode of television. You know, Randall Einhorn, Dave Rogers, Dean Holland, Claire Scanlon were all crew members who also got this opportunity, and all of us are full-time directors today because of Greg Daniels.
任何介绍的工作。然后他还发来了一段音频剪辑，讲述了执导这一集对他意味着什么。我从第一季开始就是这部剧的摄像师，非常幸运格雷格·丹尼尔斯给了我执导第一集电视剧的机会。你知道，伦纳德·爱因霍恩、戴夫·罗杰斯、迪恩·霍兰德、克莱尔·斯坎伦都是也得到了这个机会的工作人员，我们所有人今天都因为格雷格·丹尼尔斯而成为了全职导演。
His kindness and generosity to let us get these opportunities, you know, led to my career plus many other careers. Well, that is so true, and we've talked about that many times, about how Greg was such a great creative collaborator and opened the doors for so many people. Yeah. All right, are you ready for Fastback number two? I guess so. All right.
他的善良和慷慨让我们获得了这些机会，你知道，成就了我的职业生涯以及许多其他人的职业生涯。嗯，这太真实了，我们已经多次讨论过这一点，关于格雷格是多么伟大的创意合作者，并为这么多人打开了大门。是的。好了，你准备好迎接第二条快速事实了吗？我想是的。好吧。
Moving on really quickly. Well, I have a fan question from Charlie B. and Tacoma, Washington. Were the scenes at Sid and Dexter's, which is where we go for happy hour, actually filmed at a Dave and Buster's? The answer is, sort of. It was a former Dave and Buster's that is now called Gillian's. It was at Universal CityWalk. Do people know what Universal CityWalk is?
非常迅速地继续。嗯，我有一个来自华盛顿州塔科马市的查理·B.的粉丝提问。我们在欢乐时光去的西德和德克斯特餐厅的场景，实际上是在戴夫和巴斯特餐厅拍摄的吗？答案是，算是吧。那是一家以前的戴夫和巴斯特餐厅，现在叫吉莉安。它在环球城市大道。人们知道环球城市大道是什么吗？
Well, you know, we have Universal Studios, and they actually have sound stages where people are filming regularly, different TV shows, movies, but then in the back of the studio, you have a whole theme park, like up on this hilltop above it, and there's all the rides and like everything. Yeah, and then the Universal CityWalk is kind of like this big outdoor mall that's filled with restaurants and a movie theater and Gillian's. At Gillian's, they had all those games, all the arcade games and pool tables, but there were two games that we had to bring in because they were specified in the script and they
嗯，你知道，我们有环球影城，他们实际上有棚景，人们经常在那里拍摄不同的电视剧、电影，但在制片厂的后面，你有一个完整的主题公园，就像在它上面的一座小山上，那里有所有的游乐设施等等。是的，然后环球城市大道有点像这个大型露天购物中心，里面充满了餐馆、电影院和吉莉安餐厅。在吉莉安餐厅，他们有所有那些游戏，所有的街机游戏和台球桌，但有两个游戏是我们不得不带进去的，因为剧本中明确规定了它们，而它们
were not actually at the location. Which ones? Wait, wait, wait. I'm going to guess. I'm going to guess the dance thing. Yes. Okay. The basketball hoop thing?
实际上并不在该地点。哪两个？等等，等等。我来猜。我来猜跳舞机。是的。好吧。投篮机？
Nope, that was there. It figures prominently in a plot that you are involved in, Angela. Oh, whack-a-mole. Whack-a-mole. That's right. That was info thanks to Randy Cordray. And then I also asked Matt about shooting at this location because I was like, Matt, you finally get to direct an episode and it's not at Dunder Mifflin.
不对，那个就在那儿。它在你参与的剧情中占有重要地位，安吉拉。哦，打地鼠。打地鼠。没错。多亏了兰迪·科德里的信息，才知道这些。然后我还问了马特关于在这个地点拍摄的事，因为我说，马特，你终于有机会执导一集了，而且它不在邓德米夫林。
The majority of it happens at this location that we've never gone to ever and you know the wheels come off whenever we go on location. Oh, we don't travel well. Here is what Matt had to say about shooting on location. You know, one of the biggest challenges for this episode was that it was almost entirely shot on location. Charles McDougal, another one of the directors from the office, gave me a great piece of advice. He told me to go to the location and to just sit and watch, to understand where people
大部分剧情都发生在我们从未去过的这个地方，而且你知道，每当我们去外景地拍摄时，事情就会失控。哦，我们不擅长出差。以下是马特关于外景拍摄的说法。你知道，这一集最大的挑战之一是它几乎完全是在外景地拍摄的。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔，办公室的另一位导演，给了我一个很好的建议。他告诉我去外景地坐下来静静地观察，去理解人们
hang out, you know, where the waiters and waitresses travel and how people naturally work and play in that environment. So the weekend before we started shooting, I spent several hours at the Dave and Buster's at Universal City Walk, where we were shooting the episode. And you know, I just sat and watched. So I understood how to make the place feel as natural and real as possible when we were shooting the episode there. I thought it was super helpful and worked really great in the episode.
都在哪里消磨时间，你知道，服务员和女服务员的行动路线，以及人们在那种环境中是如何自然地工作和娱乐的。所以在我们开拍前的那个周末，我在我们拍摄这一集的环球城市大道的戴夫和巴斯特餐厅呆了几个小时。你知道，我只是坐着观察。所以我懂了如何在我们在那里拍摄这一集时，让这个地方感觉尽可能自然和真实。我觉得这超级有用，在这一集中效果非常好。
That's amazing advice. So smart. Incredible. Way to go, Charles McDougal. Yeah. Action! Action! I want to point out one thing.
太棒的建议了。太聪明了。难以置信。真有你的，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔。耶。开拍！开拍！我想指出一件事。
There is a DVD commentary for this episode. It has Matt Stone, Brian, Oscar, BJ, and myself. And Matt talked about shooting at Universal Studios and that it was unique for us because we had never shot anything there on the actual Universal property, even though we were an NBC Universal show. Yeah. Yeah. You know, the names didn't dexters.
这一集有一段DVD评论音轨。里面有马特·佐恩、布莱恩、奥斯卡、BJ和我自己。马特谈到了在环球影城拍摄的经历，这对我门来说很独特，因为我们以前从未在真正的环球资产上拍摄过任何东西，尽管我们是一档NBC环球的节目。是的。是的。你知道，西德和德克斯特的名字。
The reason we called it that. There's a special reason. Matt sent in an audio clip about that, too. On a fun side note, the Dave and Buster's was renamed Sid and Dexter's after my kids. It was a pitch that I had made to the writers that they seemed to like. I'm not sure the name actually made it into the show, but I have a Sid and Dexter's sign hanging up in my office from the episode. I enjoy getting to see that.
我们这样叫它的原因。有一个特殊的原因。马特也发来了一段关于这点的音频剪辑。作为一个有趣的插曲，这家戴夫和巴斯特餐厅为了我的孩子被重新命名为西德和德克斯特餐厅。这是我向编剧们提出的一项提议，他们似乎很喜欢。我不确定这个名字是否真的进入了节目中，但我的办公室里挂着一个从那一集拿来的西德和德克斯特的牌子。我很享受能看到它。
It makes me laugh. It definitely made it in the show. There are signs all throughout the bar. I took screen grabs that say Sid and Dexter's, which, you know, is his children, Sid and Dexter. Mm-hmm. But Matt, it's in. Oh, it's very in.
它让我发笑。它绝对进入了节目。整个酒吧到处都是牌子。我截了图，上面写着西德和德克斯特，你知道的，这就是他的孩子们，西德和德克斯特。嗯。但是马特，它在里面。哦，非常在里面。
I don't think any characters say the name of the place. No, but it's just there in the background. It's all over. Yeah. It's on some of the games and it's on a little window as you walk in past the bouncer. Are you ready for fast fact number three? Yes. With that, I have something from my digital clutter.
我不认为有任何角色说出这个地方的名字。没有，但它就在背景里。到处都是。是的。它在一些游戏上，也在你走过保镖时的小窗户上。你准备好迎接第三条快速事实了吗？是的。伴随这个，我有一些来自我的数字杂物的内容。
Oh. So you're going to get to play your sting. I realized I need a sting for fast fact number three because I was a lady who Googled. Oh, we need a lady who Googles sting. We really do. It's new technology. Guess what I Googled. Wait, wait.
哦。所以你要播放你的音效了。我意识到我需要为第三条快速事实准备一个音效，因为我是一个会谷歌搜索的女士。哦，我们需要一个谷歌搜索女士的音效。我们真的需要。这是新技术。你猜我谷歌搜索了什么。等等，等等。
Let me think. The episode is called Happy Hour. There are games. You could have Googled all those games, who makes those games, bars. You're overthinking it. I Googled Happy Hour. I just, I get it simple. Guess what?
让我想想。这一集叫欢乐时光。有很多游戏。你可能谷歌搜索了所有这些游戏、谁制造了这些游戏、酒吧。你把事情想得太复杂了。我谷歌搜索了欢乐时光。我只是，我把它简单化。你猜怎么着？
What? Happy Hour is a marketing term that refers to a time of day when a restaurant or bar offers reduced prices for alcoholic beverages. It is also common to find discounted appetizer and food items. However, according to Wikipedia, not everyone is happy about Happy Hour. Ooh. Did you know Happy Hour has been illegal in the Republic of Ireland since 2003 under the Intoxicating Liquor Act?
什么？欢乐时光是一个营销术语，指的是餐厅或酒吧为酒精饮料提供优惠价格的一天中的某个时间。通常也能找到打折的开胃菜和食物。然而，根据维基百科的说法，并不是每个人都对欢乐时光感到高兴。哦。你知道自2003年根据《烈性酒法案》以来，欢乐时光在爱尔兰共和国一直是非法的吗？
Oh. No Happy Hours in Ireland. Maybe people hit it too hard. For sure. In 2004, Glasgow banned Happy Hours to reduce binge drinking. Then in 2008, the province of Alberta created restrictions to Happy Hour, saying that all Happy Hour promotions had to end by 8 p.m. And then drink prices had to go back to, I guess there's something called the Alberta
哦。爱尔兰没有欢乐时光。也许人们喝得太猛了。肯定的。2004年，格拉斯哥禁止了欢乐时光以减少暴饮暴食。然后到2008年，艾伯塔省对欢乐时光出台了限制措施，规定所有的欢乐时光促销活动必须在晚上8点前结束。然后饮料价格必须回到，我猜有什么叫艾伯塔
Gaming and Liquor Commission's minimum price regulations. Put that on a label. Yeah. Like you have to charge a certain amount for alcohol. But then in 2016, they removed the restriction. So now everybody in the province of Alberta can have Happy Hour anytime. In the United States, Massachusetts was the first U.S. state to ban Happy Hour in 1984. In 2011, Utah passed a ban on Happy Hours.
博彩和酒类委员会的最低价格规定。把这个贴在标签上。是的。就像你必须对酒精收取一定的费用一样。但到了2016年，他们取消了这项限制。所以现在艾伯塔省的每个人都可以随时享受欢乐时光。在美国，马萨诸塞州是1984年第一个禁止欢乐时光的美国州。2011年，犹他州通过了禁止欢乐时光的法案。
In June 2012, Happy Hour became legal in Kansas after a 26-year ban. And in July 2015, Illinois lifted their 25-year ban on Happy Hours. But as of July 2015, Happy Hour is still banned in Alaska, Delaware, Hawaii, Indiana, Maine, Massachusetts, North Carolina, Oklahoma, Rhode Island, Utah, and Vermont. The laws were created to help stop over-serving and drunk driving. And a lot of places still have restrictions on Happy Hours. For example, in Illinois, you cannot offer a two-for-one drink special. You cannot give away drinks as a prize for a trivia night, and bars cannot host drinking
2012年6月，在经历26年的禁令后，欢乐时光在堪萨斯州合法化。2015年7月，伊利诺伊州解除了持续25年的欢乐时光禁令。但截至2015年7月，阿拉斯加州、特拉华州、夏威夷州、印第安纳州、缅因州、马萨诸塞州、北卡罗来纳州、俄克拉荷马州、罗德岛州、犹他州和佛蒙特州仍然禁止欢乐时光。这些法律的制定是为了帮助制止过度服务和酒后驾车。许多地方仍然对欢乐时光有限制。例如，在伊利诺伊州，你不能提供买一赠一的饮料特惠。你不能把饮料作为知识问答之夜的奖品，酒吧也不能举办饮酒
games. So you can have a Happy Hour, but there are rules. There are apparently no rules for Happy Hour in Pennsylvania, and so we could go to Happy Hour. So this tracks. It tracks. Yeah. Seeing as it's a Monday, and we're about to go on vacation, and we are allowed to have
游戏。所以你可以有欢乐时光，但有规则。显然宾夕法尼亚州的欢乐时光没有规则，所以我们可以去过欢乐时光。所以这很合理。很合理。是的。鉴于今天是星期一，我们即将去度假，而且我们被允许拥有
a Happy Hour, and this is the Happy Hour episode, I thought we should have an adult beverage. What? I love these episodes. I brought a mini bottle of sparkling rosé. Happy vacation, lady. I have two glasses. I have to open this.
欢乐时光，并且这是欢乐时光那一集，我想我们应该喝一杯成人饮料。什么？我喜欢这些剧集。我带了一小瓶起泡桃红葡萄酒。祝你度假愉快，女士。我有两个杯子。我得打开这个。
It's Happy Hour. How can we not have something? Oh my goodness. Well, thank you so much. You're welcome. I hope you had a hearty breakfast. I actually did. I had a gluten-free bagel from Trader Joe's, and eggs and berries.
这是欢乐时光。我们怎么能不喝点什么呢？天哪。好吧，非常感谢。不客气。希望你吃了一顿丰盛的早餐。我确实吃了。我吃了乔氏超市的无麸质百吉饼，还有鸡蛋和浆果。
Oh. I've had two bites of a banana, so this will get interesting. Okay. I'm opening the sparkling champagne. Cover your eyes. Oh gosh. Oh, that's really on there. Woo!
哦。我吃了一根香蕉的两口，所以这会变得很有趣。好的。我要打开起泡香槟了。捂住你的眼睛。哦天哪。哦，那个塞得很紧。呜！
Oh. And Sam brought cups. Well, Happy, Happy Hour to us. Happy summer. And cheers. We'll be right back after this break. We are back, you guys. And before we break down this cold open, Jenna, would you like to know what you were doing
哦。山姆带了杯子。好吧，祝我们欢乐时光快乐。夏天快乐。干杯。我们休息一下马上回来。大家，我们回来了。在我们剖析这个冷场开头之前，珍娜，你想知道你当时在做什么吗？
this week? The episode was filmed? Okay. I think it's time for Angela's Digital Clutton. I went digging into my emails. We filmed this in February, 2010. The shooting draft was dated February 22nd. On February 24th, you emailed me and said, Angela, we have next Friday off.
这一集是拍摄的？好吧。我想是时候迎来安吉拉的数字杂物了。我翻看了我的电子邮件。我们是在2010年2月拍摄的。拍摄剧本的日期是2月22日。在2月24日，你给我发邮件说，安吉拉，我们下周五休息。
I looked ahead at the schedule. So like you. Did you go with me to look at wedding dresses? And you sent me a bunch of photos. You'd already been looking a little bit, but there was one other place you wanted to go. And we did go together. And I took a bunch of photos of you trying on dresses that I then emailed to you. And one of them is the one you picked and you wore on your wedding day.
我提前看了日程表。真像你做的事。你陪我去看婚纱了吗？你给我发了一堆照片。你之前已经看了一小会儿了，但还有另一个你想去的地方。我们确实一起去了。我拍了一堆你试穿裙子的照片，然后发邮件给你。其中有一条就是你挑选的那条，你在婚礼那天穿的。
Oh my gosh. I love that. You have to send me these pictures. Okay, I purposely got them all ready to show you, but I will send them to you as well. So I remember for a short time while trying on wedding dresses, and this is reminding me of my obsession with trying to put a flower on my lapel for a book tour. I really wanted to wear a fascinator. The things that, you know, the British royal family wear, the things that are like, they're
哦，天哪。我太喜欢了。你得把这些照片发给我。好的，我特意把它们都准备好了给你看，但我也会发给你的。所以记得有那么一小段时间在试穿婚纱时，这让我想起了我试图在书签售会上把一朵花别在翻领上的执念。我真的很想戴一顶小礼帽。那种，你知道的，英国王室成员戴的东西，那种东西，它们
not really a hat. They just sort of pin to your head and they have like a big plume of a feather. And they're kind of like a floofy floofy, yes. Or maybe they have like a, you know, like a netting that goes over the eyes. Yes. You were really into that. And then you were also very into a sash. You decided you needed a dress with a sash.
不是真正的帽子。它们只是夹在你的头上，上面有一大簇羽毛。它们有点像蓬松蓬松的，是的。或者也许它们有一种，你知道的，就像盖在眼睛上的网纱。是的。你真的很喜欢那个。然后你还非常喜欢腰带。你决定你需要一件带腰带的裙子。
Oh my gosh. You're bringing the sash back, lady. Look at this. I have so many more. Oh my gosh. Yes. Well, that is what I wore. I know.
哦，天哪。你把腰带带回来了，女士。看这个。我还有更多呢。哦，天哪。是的。嗯，那就是我穿的。我知道。
That is my dress. There were lots of photos. We might have to post a few if you're okay with it. Yes, that's very fun. Okay. I like it. I love what was happening the week this episode was filmed. I love it.
那是我的裙子。有很多照片。如果你不介意的话，我们可能得发几张。好的，非常有趣。好的。我喜欢。我喜欢这一集拍摄那周发生的事情。我太喜欢了。
Well, in this cold open, what is happening is, well, what's going to eventually happen is a push-up contest. Michael sets a new record, 25 push-ups and one girl push-up. And then he challenges everyone to do better than he can and the prizes you get to go home. So at first when he floats this idea out, people are ignoring him. But when he says the prizes you get to go home, people drop to the ground. Great question from Leah J and New Albany, Indiana. Angela, I have to know.
在这个冷场开头中，正在发生的是，嗯，最终将要发生的是一场俯卧撑比赛。迈克尔创下了新纪录，25个标准俯卧撑和1个女孩俯卧撑。然后他挑战每个人做得比他好，奖品是你可以回家。所以一开始当他提出这个想法时，大家都在忽视他。但当他说奖品是你可以回家时，大家纷纷趴到了地上。来自印第安纳州新奥尔巴尼的莉亚·J提出的好问题。安吉拉，我必须知道。
Did the script tell you to do your push-ups with your legs crossed? I almost spit out my drink when I caught it. It's exactly how I would think Angela Martin would think it is appropriate for a lady to do push-ups, but I didn't recognize that until I saw the scene. It was just a brilliant detail and I love it. Angela, was it a choice or is that just how you do push-ups? It was a choice. It was not in the script.
剧本是不是告诉你交叉双腿做俯卧撑的？我看到的时候差点把饮料喷出来。这正是我认为安吉拉·马丁会觉得一位女士做俯卧撑时该有的端庄姿态，但我直到看到这个场景才意识到这一点。这真是一个绝妙的细节，我太喜欢了。安吉拉，这是你的选择，还是你本来就是这么做俯卧撑的？这是一个选择。剧本里没有写。
They didn't tell me how to do a push-up, just that my tush had to be a little higher so that Michael is like, you're disqualified, you know? So I was wearing a skirt. I'm Angela Martin. I was like, I bet Angela Martin would try to be dainty even if she did these push-ups. And so I just made the choice to cross my legs. Amazing. Thank you.
他们没有告诉我怎么做俯卧撑，只说我的屁股得稍微高一点，这样迈克尔就会说，你被取消资格了，你知道吗？所以我当时穿着裙子。我是安吉拉·马丁。我想，我打赌安吉拉·马丁即使在做这些俯卧撑时也会努力表现得娇小优雅。所以我做出了交叉双腿的选择。太棒了。谢谢。
It's an example of how well we knew our characters. I love that. Well, thank you, Leah, for noticing. We got another fan question from KDG in Greenville, South Carolina. In the commentary for this episode, BJ teases that the cold open used some movie magic to help Stanley in the push-up scene, but he wouldn't spill the beans. What exactly did Leslie have to go through to film this scene? I was not there.
这是一个我们多么了解自己角色的例子。我喜欢这样。好吧，谢谢莉亚注意到这一点。我们收到了来自南卡罗来纳州格林ville的KDG的另一个粉丝提问。在这一集的评论中，BJ调侃说冷场开头使用了某种电影魔法来帮助斯坦利完成俯卧撑场景，但他不肯透露内幕。莱斯利为了拍摄这个场景到底经历了什么？我当时不在场。
But my first thought was there is no way that they would make any of us do multiple takes of 25 push-ups. I mean, that would be insane. Yeah. And you notice John does like one half of a push-up and just says 19. Oh, we gave John so much crap for that because, you know, over in the accounting department, we do push-ups and we're in this wide shot. Yeah.
但我的第一反应是，他们绝不可能让我们任何人拍好几条25个俯卧撑。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。是的。而且你注意到约翰只做了半个俯卧撑就说19。哦，我们为那件事给了约翰很多嘲讽，因为你知道，在会计部门那边，我们要做俯卧撑，而且我们在一个广角镜头里。是的。
They couldn't hide us. Yeah. So we had to do a few push-ups every take and John only had to do one. And we were like, you suck. Oscar and I were actually sore and we weren't doing 25, but we had to do a few every time. And we shared on the commentary. We did 20 takes. Oh, my gosh.
他们藏不住我们。是的。所以我们每个镜头都得做几个俯卧撑，而约翰只需要做一个。我们当时就说，你太逊了。奥斯卡和我其实肌肉酸痛，虽然我们没做25个，但每次我们都得做几个。我们在评论中分享过。我们拍了20条。哦，天哪。
How many push-ups would that be if Stanley had to do 20 takes of 25 push-ups? No. No, do that math. No, too many. I'm tired. Too many. Too many. A lot.
如果斯坦利不得不拍20条、每条25个俯卧撑，那得是多少个俯卧撑？不。不，算算那个数学。不，太多了。我累了。太多了。太多了。很多。
25, 50, 500? Too many. 500. Too many. It's very funny to me because of all of us, John was the one who actually did push-ups every morning. I know. And then he only had to do a half a push-up.
25，50，500？太多了。500。太多了。这对我来说非常搞笑，在我们所有人中，约翰其实是每天早晨都真正做俯卧撑的那个人。我知道。然后他只需要做半个俯卧撑。
And then there, Oscar and I doing push-ups. Brian was laying face down. I don't know if you noticed that. I did not. On the ground. He shared on the commentary. And as soon as he shared it, I was like, oh, my gosh, I remember that. He had separated his shoulder.
然后，奥斯卡和我还在做俯卧撑。布莱恩趴在地上脸朝下。我不知道你们有没有注意到那个。我没有。趴在地上。他在评论里分享了。他一分享，我就想，哦，天哪，我记起来了。他的肩膀脱臼了。
Oh, that's right. Yeah. The day before we filmed this, he had had a steroid injection in his shoulder and was in quite a bit of pain. So there was no way he could do a push-up. So he got to lay face down. Good thing Kevin would probably do that. Well, I reached out to Dave Rogers, who was our editor for this episode, and also to Randy
哦，对。是的。在我们拍摄这个的前一天，他的肩膀注射了类固醇，非常痛。所以他根本不可能做俯卧撑。于是他趴在地上了。真好，凯文大概也会那样做。嗯，我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯，他是我们这一集的剪辑师，还有兰迪·科德里。
Cordray. And they told me how Stanley did all of his push-ups. So first of all, I want to say there is a citation on Dunderpedia, which I love, that claims that we used a green screen in this scene. Oh, no, we didn't. I was there. Yeah, no. No.
他们告诉我斯坦利是怎么完成所有俯卧撑的。首先，我想说在邓德百科上有一个引用，我非常喜欢，它声称我们在这一场景中使用了绿幕。哦，不，我们没有。我在现场。是的，没有。没有。
Randy said, not true. Not true. Also, you were there. But what they did do was they built like a mini seesaw. And Leslie could lay on it, and then it was sort of covered up by his jacket that was hanging. And both Randy and Dave said, if you notice, you mostly only see the top half of him doing the push-up, and his body was supported by this plank.
兰迪说，完全没有。完全没有。而且你在现场。但他们做的是搭建了一个迷你跷跷板。莱斯利可以躺在上面，然后被他挂着的夹克稍微遮挡了一下。兰迪和戴夫都说，如果你注意看，你主要只能看到他做俯卧撑的上半身，而他的身体是由这块木板支撑的。
I want to point out something. So yes, Leslie didn't have to do 25 push-ups each take. But the way he had to lay on the plank, and they were sort of helping him elevate his torso, he still was in a plank position, guys. Like, that was still strenuous. Oh, yeah. I mean, he was still doing a form of a push-up, even though they were giving him a little bit of support.
我想指出一件事。所以是的，莱斯利每条不用做25个俯卧撑。但他躺在木板上的方式，以及他们以某种方式帮他抬高上半身，他仍然处于平板支撑的姿势，伙计们。这依然很吃力。哦，是的。我的意思是，即使他们给予了他一点支持，他仍然在做某种形式的俯卧撑。
Yeah. So I feel like some of that sweat you see is real, because Leslie was getting a workout. Well, in the wide shot at 1 minute 42 seconds, you see him in a full push-up position, no plank. And then there are some really quick edits that are just masterful. You see him go down, and then they push in, and you only see feet around him when he comes up. That's because they played that footage in reverse.
是的。所以我觉得你看到的那些汗水是真的，因为莱斯利确实在锻炼。嗯，在1分42秒的广角镜头中，你看到他处于完全的俯卧撑姿势，没有木板。然后有一些非常快速的剪辑，简直是神乎其技。你看到他下去，然后他们推镜头，当他起来时你周围只能看到脚。那是因为他们把那段素材倒放了。
Oh, so smart. Yeah. And then they quickly cut to a wide shot of him fully up and everyone cheering. That's how we did it. Well, Oscar has a great talking head that kind of wraps up the moment. He says, it's like those stories where a mother lifts the car to save her baby. Like, Stanley is so determined to go home. He does 25 push-ups.
哦，太聪明了。是的。然后他们迅速切到一个他完全起来、大家都在欢呼的广角镜头。我们就是这么拍的。嗯，奥斯卡有一个很棒的单人访谈，算是为这个时刻做了个总结。他说，这就像那些母亲举起汽车为了救她孩子的感人故事。就像斯坦利决心要回家一样。他做了25个俯卧撑。
Do you think you could do 25 push-ups right now? Heck no. Really? Why is that surprising to you? What about like, you know, on your knees, like the knee push-ups, not a full push-up? Could you do 25 of those? No. Hmm.
你觉得你现在能做25个俯卧撑吗？见鬼，不能。真的吗？为什么这会让你感到惊讶？比如，你知道的，用膝盖着地的那种，膝盖俯卧撑，而不是完全的俯卧撑？你能做25个那种吗？不能。嗯。
You sound like you think you can. I don't know if I can. I know I can do 10 to 12. I bet I could do 10. I don't want to do it, though. I'm sitting. I'm sitting, Rose, and like, I'm not moving. But here's the thing.
听起来你觉得自己能行。我不知道我能不能。我知道我能做10到12个。我打赌我能做10个。不过我不想做。我坐着。罗斯，我坐着，而且我不想动。但问题是。
I'm very competitive. So if you were like, we're going to do 10, I would just because I'm like stubborn and I'm like, I will do it, but I'm not doing it. Now you're gearing me up. No, we're not doing it. I'm also very competitive. I know. This is why we're great business partners.
我很好胜。所以如果你说，我们要去做10个，我就会去，因为我很固执，我会想，我会做，但我现在不做。你现在在激我。不，我们不做。我也很好胜。我知道。这就是为什么我们是极好的商业伙伴。
But we're going to agree right now to not do it. Here's what we're agreeing to. What? We can do 10, right, on our knees. We believe that we can do 10. So we've basically done them. I love it. This episode begins with Oscar arriving to work at 7 a.m., like he always does.
但我们现在达成一致不做。我们达成的一致是。什么？我们可以做10个，对吧，用膝盖。我们相信我们可以做10个。所以我们基本上已经做过了。我太喜欢了。这一集以奥斯卡像往常一样在早上7点到达工作地点开始。
Sure. He always gets there super early while the door is still locked. He's trying to position himself so that he can see Matt from the warehouse. Well, coming super early works, he gets to see Matt, have a little chit chat, and then he shares that, you know, besides this morning, they also had talked at Christmas. So you know, a little bit of momentum. I have a continuity catch. I do.
当然。他总是到得超早，那时门还锁着。他试图调整自己的位置，以便能看到仓库的马特。嗯，来得超早确实管用，他能看到马特，聊一会儿天，然后他分享说，除了今天早上，他们之前在圣诞节也聊过。所以，你知道的，有一点进展。我发现了一个连贯性失误。我发现了。
Me, Jenna Fisher, has a continuity catch. Oh, well, let's hear it. Matt and Oscar were both at the bar on St. Patrick's Day, which is between this morning and Christmas. What do you think of that? I think that is fantastic background catch. Thank you. You're welcome.
我，珍娜·费舍，发现了一个连贯性失误。哦，说来听听。马特和奥斯卡都在圣帕特里克节那天去了酒吧，那是在今天早上和圣诞节之间。你对这个怎么看？我觉得这是一个非常棒的背景穿帮发现。谢谢。不客气。
Randy said that everyone actually came in extra early to shoot this. You know, we would usually start coming in to work around 5.30 a.m., and we would be shooting by 7. He said that on this day, Matt really wanted to get that very early morning light in the sky to sell that it was early morning. You son of a gun. You could have sold it. Well, we were rolling by 6.12 a.m.
兰迪说，每个人其实都提前很久来拍这个。你知道，我们通常会在早上5点半左右开始来上班，7点左右开始拍摄。他说在那天，马特真的很想捕捉天空中那种大清早的光线，以营造出这是清早的感觉。你这个老机灵鬼。你还真能营造出来。嗯，我们在早上6点12分就已经开机了。
Oh my goodness. That meant you and I maybe got to sleep in a little, though. Maybe so. Maybe so. Later that morning, Oscar is going to go into Daryl's office. This is one of my favorite scenes of the whole episode. I thought that Craig and Oscar just crushed it. It's so awkward.
哦，天哪。这意味着你和我可能稍微多睡了一会儿，不过。也许吧。也许吧。那天晚些时候，奥斯卡要走进达里尔的办公室。这是整集中我最喜欢的场景之一。我觉得克雷格和奥斯卡演得太绝了。太尴尬了。
There's like all of that dead air between them. And BJ shared on the commentary that he really loved how slowly the scene played out. Like they really wanted all of those awkward silences. This is one of those character combinations. We haven't really seen, and I love it. And they have moments throughout the episode that are so good. I have some questions about the stuff on Daryl's desk. You do?
他们之间有那么多冷场。BJ在评论中分享说，他真的很喜欢这个场景发展得如此缓慢。就像他们真的需要所有那些尴尬的沉默一样。这是那种我们没怎么见过的角色组合，我太喜欢了。他们在整集中都有非常精彩的时刻。我对达里尔桌子上的东西有一些疑问。是吗？
Yeah. Let's hear it. I got a little distracted. What? Here is what I saw. There's a mailbox. It's like a little, fakey mailbox that might also be a bank. Like a piggy bank?
是的。说来听听。我有点分心了。什么？这就是我看到的。有一个邮箱。就像一个小小的、假装的邮箱，它也可能是一个存钱罐。像小猪存钱罐？
Yeah. Yeah. And then there's a baseball, not a real baseball, but like a baseball replica that might also be a bank. Maybe Daryl has a thing for piggy banks. This is my question because there is also a ceramic statue, kind of like the kind your kid would make at like a Color Me Mine, which is an amazing detail because he has a daughter. I think the statue is also a bank.
对。对。然后还有一个棒球，不是真的棒球，而是一个棒球复制品，也可能是一个存钱罐。也许达里尔对存钱罐情有独钟。这就是我的疑问，因为还有一个陶瓷雕像，有点像你家孩子在“画我瓷”那种地方会做的那种，这是一个绝妙的细节，因为他有个女儿。我觉得那个雕像也是个存钱罐。
Does Daryl collect banks? That's adorable. I'm saying. I just think it's so cute if he collects piggy banks. I'm going to be on the lookout. I need to know. Including the awkward silences and all the piggy banks, Oscar's like, you know what? We should all go out like the warehouse and the office and he's like, when's the last
达里尔收集存钱罐吗？太可爱了。我是说。我只是觉得如果他收集小猪存钱罐，那就太可爱了。我要留意一下。我得知道。包括那些尴尬的沉默和所有的存钱罐，奥斯卡说，你知道吗？我们应该一起出去玩，比如仓库和办公室的人，然后他说，上一次是什么时候？
time? Yeah. We went to happy hour and Daryl's like, has that ever happened? So Oscar is on a mission. He's trying to have some time with Matt, but he's going to like set up this whole happy hour outing. And Daryl's like, all right. So now Oscar's going to go around the office and invite everyone.
对。我们去过欢乐时光，而达里尔说，那发生过吗？所以奥斯卡带着任务来的。他试图和马特共度一些时光，但他打算发起这场欢乐时光郊游。达里尔说，好吧。所以现在奥斯卡要在办公室里走来走去邀请所有人。
Phyllis's response is hilarious. She says, you know what? I saw a new drink on TV. So yeah, I'd like to try that. I'm going to go. And her talking head, she says, I love going to bars with Bob. I tend to wear something low cut and get men to flirt with me and Bob beats them up. And then she looks at Cameron goes, what?
菲yllis的反应太搞笑了。她说，你知道吗？我在电视上看到了一种新饮料。所以，是的，我想试试那个。我要去。在她的单人访谈中，她说，我喜欢和鲍勃一起去酒吧。我往往会穿低胸的衣服，让男人调情，然后鲍勃会揍他们。然后她看着卡梅伦说，什么？
The what wasn't scripted. I went to the shooting draft because I was so curious. That's my favorite part. I know me too. It wasn't scripted. Phyllis improvised that. That's brilliant. What?
那个“什么”不是剧本里写的。我查了拍摄剧本，因为我太好奇了。那是我的最爱。我知道我也是。这不是剧本里的。菲yllis是即兴发挥的。太绝了。什么？
What? Jim says he'd love to join for happy hour, but Pam is like probably just going to want to have a night in. But Andy insists that Jim call Pam right now this minute and ask her. Oh yeah. Andy's like, no, no, no. I call BS on that. Pam's going to want to go.
什么？吉姆说他很想参加欢乐时光，但帕姆可能只想在家度过一个安静的夜晚。但安迪坚持让吉姆现在、立刻给帕姆打电话问问。哦，是的。安迪说，不，不，不。我觉得那纯属胡扯。帕姆会想去的。
And she does. She's so excited. We got a fan question from Maddie B and Akron, Ohio and many others who said at four minutes and 44 seconds, Jim has a talking head where Pam is over the phone talking to the camera crew. It kind of sounds like she says, Creed, Brian, Stanley. Did Jenna say Brian on mistake? Does she mean to be talking about Kevin?
而且她确实去了。她太兴奋了。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州阿克伦市的Maddie B以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们说在4分44秒时，吉姆有一个单人访谈，当时帕姆正在电话里跟摄像组说话。听起来她好像在说，克雷格、布莱恩、斯坦利。珍娜是口误说成布莱恩了吗？她是想说凯文吗？
Or did the script say Ryan and Brian just slipped out by accident? I want you guys to hear it. So some of the co-workers were thinking of going out tonight, but I told them. Yes. I would love to. Ha! Knew it. It's been so long since I've been with adults, but I am so excited to see everybody.
还是剧本里写的是瑞安，而布莱恩不小心溜出来了？我想让你们听听看。所以一些同事今晚考虑出去玩，但我告诉他们。是的。我很想去。哈！猜到了。我好久没和成年人在一起了，但我太高兴能见到大家了。
Creed, Brian. Oh my God, Stanley. Stanley's going to be there. Yes. Oh my God. I did not say the first time. I heard Ryan while I looked in the script because I at first also thought it sounded a little like Brian, but the script says Ryan.
克雷格，布莱恩。哦天哪，斯坦利。斯坦利要在那里。是的。哦天哪。我第一次没说。当我看着剧本时我听到了瑞安，因为我一开始也觉得听起来有点像布莱恩，但剧本写的是瑞安。
And I think just now isolating it onto headphones where all I'm hearing is the audio, I think I hear Ryan. Yeah. I hear Ryan. But Maddie, the first time when I was watching the episode, I also heard Brian. And I would not put it past us to flip in someone's real name. This was like Laurel. Remember that?
我想刚才把它单独隔离到耳机里，我听到的全都是音频，我觉得我听到的是瑞安。是的。我听到的是瑞安。但Maddie，我第一次看这一集时，我也听到了布莱恩。而且我不排除我们会顺嘴说出某人的真名。这就像劳尔。还记得那个吗？
No. What was that? Oh my gosh. You guys. Sam, Cassie. What's Laurel? The whole thing that went viral of like, do you hear Laurel or Yanni? Remember?
不。那是什么？哦，天哪。你们。山姆，卡西。什么是劳尔？在网上疯传的那个问题：你听到的是“劳尔”还是“扬尼”？记得吗？
Oh, I do remember this. This was like one of the bluer, white dress moments. I remember this. Yes. Did you hear that for Jenna? Yes, please hold on. I'll hunt that down. Laurel, tell me what you hear.
哦，我记得这个。这就像蓝黑裙还是白金裙的时刻之一。我记得这个。是的。珍娜，你听到那个了吗？是的，请稍等。我去把它找出来。劳尔，告诉我你听到了什么。
Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. I hear Laurel. Laurel. So do I.
劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。我听到的是劳尔。劳尔。我也是。
What do you guys hear? I hear Laurel. I hear Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. Laurel. Do we hear Laurel because right before we played this clip, we were all thinking Laurel.
你们听到的是什么？我听到的是劳尔。我听到的是劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。劳尔。我们听到劳尔是因为在我们播放这段音频之前，我们都在想劳尔吗？
And because I said Laurel, but I'm telling you, is there another one that we can use? When I heard it, I heard Laurel the very first time years ago. So we all heard Laurel, but according to an article in 2018 on The Guardian, this short audio clip of a computer-generated voice became the most divisive subject on the internet since the gold-blue dress of 2015. The audio illusion which first appeared on Reddit seems to be saying one word, but whether that word is Yanni or Laurel is the source of furious disagreement. Is this a decibel thing?
并且因为我说的是劳尔，但我告诉你们，还有另一个我们可以用的吗？当我听到它时，几年前我第一次听到就是劳尔。所以我们都听到了劳尔，但根据《卫报》2018年的一篇文章，这段由电脑合成声音的短音频剪辑成为了自2015年金蓝裙子以来互联网上最具分裂性的主题。这个首次出现在红迪网上的音频错觉似乎只在说一个词，但这个词究竟是扬尼还是劳尔，引发了激烈的争论。这是个分贝问题吗？
According to this article, it says that the sound can be seen in two ways and often the mind flips back and forth between the two interpretations. This happens because the brain can't decide on a definitive interpretation. I don't understand what that means. Is it a decibel thing? I want it to be a decibel thing. Right. A scientist that contributed to this article said, the secret is frequency, but some of
根据这篇文章，它说这个声音可以从两个方面来看，而且大脑往往在这两种解释之间来回切换。发生这种情况是因为大脑无法对明确的解释做出决定。我不明白那是什么意思。这是个分贝问题吗？我希望它是个分贝问题。对。为这篇文章贡献力量的一位科学家说，秘诀在于频率，但其中有些
it also is the mechanics of your ears and what you're expecting to hear. Most sounds, including an L and a Y, which are among the ones at issue here, are made up of several frequencies at once. Frequencies of the Y might have been made artificially higher and the frequencies that make the L sound might have dropped. So whether it's Brian or Ryan or Laurel or Yanni has something to do with frequency. Very interesting. Thank you, Angela.
原因也来自于你耳朵的力学结构以及你期望听到的是什么。大多数声音，包括这里有争议的L和Y，都是由几个频率同时构成的。Y的频率可能是被人为调高了，而发出L音的频率可能下降了。所以到底是布莱恩、瑞安，还是劳尔或扬尼，都与频率有关。非常有趣。谢谢你，安吉拉。
You're welcome. That was an impromptu tangent. Before we move on from the scene, on the DVD commentary, I shared how incredibly relatable Pam's reaction to an adult outing was as a new mom. It brought me back. You know, my kids are teenagers now, but I was still a young mom at this point. I want you to hear it. The only problem is Pam's at home with the baby and I think she wants a night in.
不客气。那是一次即兴的离题。在我们从这个场景转开之前，在DVD评论音轨中，我分享了作为新手妈妈，帕姆对成人外出游玩的反应是多么令人深有同感。这勾起了我的回忆。你知道，我的孩子现在已经是青少年了，但在那个时候我还是个年轻的妈妈。我想让你们听听。唯一的问题是帕姆在家带孩子，我觉得她想度过一个安静的夜晚。
Oh, baloney. Ring her up. Absolutely. I can totally relate to this moment. FYI. Oh, yeah. What do you mean? Just having a baby and like.
哦，胡说。给她打电话。绝对的。我完全能感同身受这一刻。顺便说一句。哦，真的吗？什么意思？就是生了个孩子，然后。
Oh, did you have a baby? Oh, I had the best baby ever who turned two just a day ago. Oh, my God. Already? Yeah. Oh, my gosh, I did this DVD commentary right after Isabelle's birthday. So sweet. I know.
哦，你生孩子了吗？哦，我生了有史以来最棒的宝宝，她刚在一天前满两岁。哦，天哪。这么快？是的。哦，天哪，我是在伊莎贝尔生日之后马上做的这个DVD评论。太甜了。我知道。
It just brought me back. But yes, I so related to Pam. And now we're doing this rewatch very shortly after Isabelle's birthday again. 14. This episode is very significant for Isabelle's birthdays. I know. Well, I can really relate to this too because I remember the first time I went to the grocery store after my son was born, I ran into Amy Adams at the grocery store.
这勾起了我的回忆。但是的，我对帕姆深有同感。现在我们在伊莎贝尔生日过后不久又在做这个重温播客了。14岁。这一集对伊莎贝尔的生日非常有意义。我知道。嗯，我对此也深有同感，因为我记得我儿子出生后我第一次去杂货店时，我在杂货店遇到了艾米·亚当斯。
She had also just had a baby and we stood in the aisle for 30 minutes just talking about how we couldn't believe that we were at the grocery store and we were like, it was as if we had gone to like a huge party, but really we were just in a grocery store, but we were so tickled to be like out of the house doing something. For sure. New parents, you go to the grocery store, it's like an exotic vacation. Exactly. Andy and Aaron are continuing to do this thing where they act like they don't like each
她也刚刚生了孩子，我们在过道里站了30分钟，只在谈论我们怎么不敢相信我们竟然在杂货店里，我们俩都觉得，就好像我们去参加了一个盛大的派对，但实际上我们只是在杂货店，不过我们能离开家做点事情感到非常高兴。肯定的。新手父母，你去了杂货店，就像去了一趟异国度假。完全正确。安迪和艾琳继续做着这种假装他们互相讨厌的事情。当然，艾琳总是把它推向最随意的境地。她说，再那样跟我说话，我就割掉你的脸。
other. Of course, Aaron always takes it to like the most random places. She's like, talk to me like that again and I'll cut your face off. I know. What? Also, they're pretending like they're not in a relationship, but clearly everyone knows. Definitely Kevin knows. They have a talking head where they're telling the camera crew that they're going to keep
我知道。什么？还有，他们假装没有在谈恋爱，但显然每个人都知道。凯文肯定知道。他们有一个单人访谈，在里面他们告诉摄像组他们要把恋情保持低调，但凯文敲了敲窗户，开始做很多手势。是的。如果你看到5分25秒，凯文正在做的手势据说是以前从未在电视上出现过的。
their romance low key, but Kevin knocks on the window and he starts making a lot of gestures. Yes. If you go to five minutes, 25 seconds, the hand gesture that Kevin is doing had supposedly never been done on television before. Yeah. It's like the one for intercourse where you have like the finger and then the circle. Yeah. You know, Randy sent me the exact note from the NBC broadcast standards and practices.
是的。就像那个代表性行为的手势，有一个手指和一个圆圈。是的。你知道，兰迪把NBC广播标准和实践部门的确切便条发给了我。
What did they say? This was after they submitted the shooting draft, where in the shooting draft it says that Kevin is going to make sexual gestures in the background. The note said, page nine, scene 17, as discussed with Randy Cordray, please shoot some alternates for Kevin's quote sex gesture with his hands toward Andy and Aaron. So Randy said they did lots of different gestures. I guess BJ and Matt Stone told Brian, just go crazy. Do every gesture you can think of.
They sent a cut over to NBC with all of the gestures in one take and it was approved. I can't believe it. He couldn't believe it either. He was like, I don't understand. We were sure that was not going to make it in. Who knew? I guess after all of our boners, they just gave up on us. They were tired.
I mean, after Phyllis got flashed in the parking lot, they just let it go. Well, Andy is going to invite Michael out for drinks. This is Michael's best day of his life. He's so excited. He announces, ladies and gentlemen, it's quitting time. Andy's like, no, no, I'm sorry. I meant later, you know, like later. Well in the background of the scene, Angela is watching everything.
It's kind of clocking Dwight. Like I wonder if Dwight's going to be going and there would have been a talking head here. It's in deleted scenes. Angela shares about what she does outside of work. Oh, at the office, I am all business, very professional, but sometimes at night, I like to go out and let my hair down. Not literally, of course, but and then there was a candy bag alt. Oh my gosh.
There are a lot of good candy bag alts for talking heads in this. It didn't make it in the episode. It is in the bloopers and you'll see why. It's not like I'm meeting anyone on chat roulette. I was so southern. Did you hear it? Oh my goodness. It's not like I'm meeting anyone on chat roulette.
I mean, they were like, yeah, we can't use that. Just get another one. Well Pam and Jim are going to arrive. Pam's hair. Who? I'm on her hair. I was going to say, like, did she like go to a salon? She's all dolled up.
I mean, we talked about it. She's excited to be out. She has on multiple necklaces and very like foofy hair. Yeah. She's walking across the parking lot with Jim. That's when she tells him that she's invited a friend for Michael. I mean, that's how much she has forgotten. Like she's done her hair.
She's got her necklaces on. She's inviting people to set them up with Michael. Pam, Pam, she runs into Kevin, who starts fake crying like at her boobs. Jenna, I shared on the commentary that Rain did that to me as a joke. Did it work? No. But thanks Rain for fake crying at my boobs while I was breastfeeding. I wonder if that's where they got the idea.
Well, actually, Brian said that this joke was not in the table draft. And after the table read, Steve Carell pitched it to the writers. I love it. I don't know if you noticed in this scene, but the ground is all wet. Did you notice? I did notice. Randy told me it was a rainy day. Oh, we shot this on February 24th, 2010.
February is a very rainy month in Los Angeles. Also, in the background, you can see the parking structure for the Universal Studios Tour. Oh my gosh. Have you ever done it? Yes. Me too. So fun. Have they updated it?
Because when I did it, it was like Jaws and Back to the Future. Same. And the Psycho House. Right. Yeah. The old lady in the rocking chair up in the window. All of it. Yeah.
I don't know. Surely it's been updated. With movies that are more timely. Right. Right. I think Jaws still comes at you, though. Right, right. You got to love the Jaws.
You're going across what looks like a pond and then Jaws comes at you. It's so fun. Well as everyone is arriving, they walk past the bouncer into the bar. You can see the sit and dexter sign. Mm-hmm. And in the deleted scenes, there was a montage of people arriving. Kevin and Meredith walk in and they cannot believe that Oscar is there. They say he's a snob.
It's in the deleted scenes. Here's how Oscar defends himself. I'm not a snob. I hate the opera. Well, the Philadelphia opera. Yikes. He defends himself on being a snob by listing what opera he is not a fan of. Then there was a deleted scene as Angela Martin arrives.
She's very dolled up. This was one of my favorite scenes to shoot because it had really silly busy work. The bouncer has asked for her ID and here it is. Good evening. Hey, you're fine. No. I have my ID here somewhere. Oh, no, you're fine.
No. You need it. That's the rule. Do with it. No. You always know where it is and then when you need it, you don't, you know, that happens. Oh, come on. It is almost a minute of me going through my purse.
I'm pulling out to shoes, coupons, all kinds of things and the bouncer is like, you're fine. I'm like, no, no, no, no, no. It was so much fun to shoot, but I get why it couldn't make it in the episodes already long. You don't need a minute of me going through my purse, but those are like my favorite moments. Well, I disagree.
I would love nothing more than to see one minute of Angela emptying her purse because I'd like to know what she keeps in her purse. I find those details fascinating. Well, a lot of tissues and coupons. Well now Pam and Jim are going to invite Michael to play pool with them. They need a fourth. That's because the third person in the group is the friend. Yeah.
And they want to make an introduction. Also, at this time, Oscar is noting that Matt is not there. No. Sort of a bummer. He keeps eyeing the door. The whole reason for this whole night. Yes. Michael is going to hit it off with Pam's friend, Julie.
Yeah, they're really getting along great. I mean, Julie laughs at everything. Yes. So Michael is happy. Guest star alert, Julie was played by Lori Notten-Oaken. She has been on Friends, Samantha Who. She's a big groundlings person and you knew her, right, Inge? Yes.
I did a sketch comedy show with her. She had written this show and I played a small part in it called Balls Out. Ooh. I know. And it was a really fun show. Well, there's going to be another guest star. It is Isabelle, played by Kellyn Coleman. She's back and she's come to the bar as well.
But you know what? She's going to say hi to Pam and then maybe mingle, which means go find Dwight. That's right. At seven minutes, 57 seconds, you might notice Angela's bright red lipstick. BJ shared on the commentary that he really wanted Angela to seem like she had tried to go all out for this evening to get Dwight's attention. He wanted her to wear the brightest lipstick that our makeup department had. And he said, he thought that this is what Angela would think you do.
Like maybe she's seen a soap opera, like how you get your guy, how you go to a bar, put on hot red lipstick. And he also shared that he was bummed because he wanted the lipstick to be even brighter red. But that was all the makeup department had. Wow. Even brighter. Yeah.
It really stands out already. I know. Well, Pam's friend Julie is going to have a talking head where it's clear she kind of likes Michael. Yeah. We had a fan catch from Corrin F in Columbus, Ohio, who says, starting at eight minutes, 52 seconds, when Pam's friend is doing her talking head about Michael, you can see Jim laughing at something Pam said.
Was this a genuine reaction to something Jenna said or was this planned? Are they acting? Either way, it's a very cute background moment. I think it's just you two in the background. Oh, no. This is 100% us in the background. Just chatting. Well, I'm very proud because I've clearly said something that has made John noodle.
Because the noodle laugh. I know he totally turns into like this like gelatinous thing that flops around when he's really tickled. Yes. I don't know what I said. Jim is there as well, but I'm very proud. I'm clearly hilarious. And there it is in the background.
Proof of funny. Thank you. We also got a fan question from both Kyle T and Houston, Texas, and Alana D from Ontario, Canada. They ask, why does Pam keep trying to set up Michael? It didn't work with her landlady and look how he treated her mom. Why? That's very valid.
Very valid. She has clearly forgotten something has happened to her while she's on maternity leave. She has mom brain. I guess so. You know, when you're tired and you're up all night and you're just like, oh, yeah, that sounds great. I don't know. I think mom brain also sometimes gives you just like an optimism.
Yes. That is, I don't know. You suddenly. You want to see the good in people. Yes, exactly. You have this newfound empathy and optimism. And compassion. Yeah.
But unfortunately, it's not going to go well. It might have if Jim hadn't spilled the beans. I know. If Jim would have just let Michael keep being himself, but Jim said, yeah, I guess Pam was right. You know, you guys are hitting it off. Light bulb. Michael's like, what?
What? I'm on a date. I'm on a date. Yeah. He's going to turn into date, Mike. Let's take a break because there's a lot to unpack here and we will discuss. We are back and date Mike is here. He has put on his kingle hat.
The script specifically called for Michael to put on a kingle hat. I got curious. So for the second time, I became a lady who Googled and I found out that the kingle hats, which I was familiar with has a long history. It goes way back. A gentleman named Jacques Henry Durgan, a World War One soldier returned from the war and he began designing berets. And in 1938, he started a company and his berets were worn by many British soldiers during
World War Two. He named his company Kangl and in the 1960s, they got the rights to create all the hats worn by the Beatles. What? Yeah. They distributed all headgear that bore the Beatles name or image. Wow. In 1981, the brand enlisted a world famous hat designer named Graham Smith to develop
a luxurious yet affordable collection called Graham Smith for Kangl and in 1983, Princess Diana appeared in Vogue wearing one of those hats. Also in 1983, they decided to create a logo and because Americans kept asking for the kangaroo hat, instead of the Kangl hat, they decided to make their logo a kangaroo. Also in the 1980s, MCs like Slick Rick and Run DMC started wearing Kangl in their videos and on stage and they really rocketed the fame thanks to LL Cool J who wore their Bermuda casual hat on his album cover for radio. LL Cool J wore their hats all the time and really pushed it to the forefront of hip hop
fashion and then you know, of course, Samuel Jackson. He loves them. Still known for loving his Kangl hat. In 2012, he teamed up with the brand and created a line called Kangl Golf by Samuel L. Jackson. It was geared toward golf enthusiasts. He loves these hats so much that in 2022, he was on the Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon and he talked about all his hats. Here's an audio clip.
Two, is it true that you own over 800 Kangl hats? My wife got rid about 500 of them. Okay. Yeah. Down to 300. Down to 300. When did you start wearing those? Oh, geez.
When I stole my first one out of my grandfather's closet. Yeah. Long time ago. Do you remember? What color? Black? My grandfather's? Yeah.
No, it was like a, it was a plattie hat, you know. It's one of those patterns. It's stylish, too. Yeah. Yeah. How about that? He has 300. His grandfather had one.
I mean, I have to think he has more now. Is 2022, do you think his wife let him add to it? Maybe. Maybe it's like the thing where you add one, but take one away so you get new stuff. Right. There was quite a bit of debate in the writer's room about the difference in regular mic and date mic. Okay.
BJ talked about it on the DVD commentary. He said there were pitches to make date mic even bigger and his clothes more extravagant. Like in one pitch, they had him wearing a dragon t-shirt or some Ed Hardy clothes, but Steve said he thought it was less of a wardrobe change and more of a personality change. So they went with a kingle hat. Well, I loved it. When Michael returns, Jim and Pam are surprised. They noticed the shift right away.
I improvised the line, why are you wearing a hat now? So I looked at the table draft, like you said Angela, and originally he had changed his shirt and Pam had a line where she said, why are you wearing a different shirt now? But then by the shooting draft, that had been taken out and there was just nothing. Pam didn't have a line there, but I think I must have remembered that shirt line, which made me laugh. And so I added, why are you wearing a hat now? Well, I loved it.
I loved Pam and Jim's reaction. They know now everything's going to go south. Michael has this big swagger. He's spinning this pull stick around at nine minutes, 40 seconds when Michael shoots the pull ball and it goes flying at you guys. Yes. Matt Stone shared that Steve really did that and thankfully they got it in the first take. Oh my gosh.
Yeah. I didn't remember that. You guys ducked for real. Well meanwhile, Kelly and Ryan are about to finish an intense round of their dance game. This is Erin and Andy are approaching. We had a fan catch from Claire L in Toronto, Canada, who says when Ryan and Kelly say they lost at 10 minutes, 37 seconds, the screen shows that their dance round is actually still going on.
It's true. Randy told me that they turned off the sound for the machine, but they kept the graphics going. They added all the music and arcade sounds in post production. So it sounds like their game has wound down. But if you catch the screen, it's still going. I have two things to share about the actual games and what we were doing. Ryan said that he really was playing that racing game and that it was actually really
fun and he played it for hours because he had to be in the background. Oh my gosh. And then in the deleted scenes, I thought it was so fun. You find out that Meredith is really good at playing pool. She keeps sinking all of these shots. She's a total pool shark. Was Kate actually sinking the shots? I doubt it.
It looked really good. I don't know. Can I tell you something? Are you really good at pool? Yeah. Really? You're also good at poker. You're good at like bar sports.
My father-in-law recently on a trip to Texas, we rented a house together, Lee's whole side of the family, and there was a pool table. And he was kind of surprised that I was such a good pool player. And he said, I have to ask, like you went to an all girls high school, you have no brothers, you're not much of a drinker, how are you so good at poker and pool? I have the same question. When I was in high school, my friend Stacey and I, by the way, Stacey, the inventor of the tan baster, the two of us in high school, we got a little obsessed with pool after we
watched the movies, The Hustler and the Color of Money. Paul Newman. Yeah. Yeah. Those sweet blue eyes. So you watched these movies and then you were like, I'm going to learn pool? Yeah. We went to a pool hall in Kirkwood, Missouri, and we learned how to play pool.
And our plan was that we were going to go on the road and we were going to hustle people. This was our grand plan to become pool hustlers. So when you weren't playing field hockey, we were going to be professional pool hustlers. Professional hustlers. Okay. We got very good. I believe it. And I really enjoyed this episode because it was my chance to kind of show off some of
my skills. My husband's very good at pool and he wants a pool table. Oh. I'm like, what? So we're not going to have a dining table? So you're going to have a pool table? I'll be over all the time. Well, it might happen.
Oh, I want to say something about this arcade dance game. Would you be surprised to know that they are not playing dance dance revolution? I feel like this is like a leading question. I don't know the answer. That's the only game I know up with the feet. The thing. Me too. Yeah, that's it.
Okay. Okay. No, there's another one. It's called pump it up. It is the other music video game dance series. It's by a Korean arcade game producer. The original version of the game was released in South Korea in August of 1999. Here's the difference.
Dance dance revolution only has four squares that you can step on and they're in like a plus sign. Yeah. Pump it up has five things you can press on. You can press the middle square and then it makes like an X. Yeah. I took screen grabs. I mom detect of it and it's not dance dance revolution.
It's pump it up. That's what they're playing and they had to bring it in. I know this happens later in the episode, but when you see Creed dancing on that thing, he really was and we did a bunch of takes. And I remember we were like, wait, I think Creed's like getting lightheaded. We need to give him a break. He's been dancing for a long time. Yeah.
When I was trading messages with Matt, he was like, I think we almost killed Creed because he did so many takes of the dancing game. And he was going all out. Randy said that they also had a graphic made and you don't see it in the episode, but it shows that Creed has all of the top 10 high scores on the leaderboard. That's awesome. And I guess the reason they did all that was because originally the tag to this episode was going to be Creed on the dance machine and you see that he's like dance master.
With a crowd around him. But then they moved it to the middle of the episode. Coming up next is probably my most famous meme that I'm a part of. What? No. There are more famous memes. No. Not for me.
Come on. I am telling you, for real, this is the most famous meme I'm in. They will take this moment where Angela sneaks up on Dwight and they'll caption it. It's someone reacting to something that scares the crap out of them and they drop the F-bomb. And it's been recycled over and over. So like over you, they'll write spiders or they'll write something that is scary. Orphobia, basically. Yes.
I titled this scene Lurk Much. Should we set it up? Yes. Okay. Well Dwight and Isabel are walking through the arcade. They're flirting. Chatting. Angela and her bright red lipstick is just all up on their heels.
And then after Isabel walks away, Dwight is completely shocked that Angela was standing there and has a very large reaction. Lady we got mail. Good question from Desi C. in Stillwell, Oklahoma. In the scene with Dwight and Isabel walking and Angela falling close behind, Isabel seems to be of equal height to Dwight, making Angela look so small in comparison. Was this done intentionally or just a happy accident? I looked up actress Kellen Coleman and her height, according to IMDb, is five nine and
a half. But standing next to rain, she looks almost to be the same height. It was intentional. You know, rain is six three, Kellen is very tall. And I am five one, wardrobe purposely for this episode put me in flats to really accentuate the height difference. Normally I wore heels on the show. I'm in flats.
BJ also shared it was his idea that only the top of my head would be visible as I walked behind them. I went to the shooting draft and here's how it described the scene. Dwight and Isabel strolled the arcade area looking for a game to play. Angela trails behind only the top of her head in frame. Amazing. Well, I will add that I remember Kellen was in heels. They put her in some like three inch kind of not wedges, but like thick heeled shoes
so that she would be super tall compared to you. We got another fan question from Xenia W in British Columbia Dwight looks utterly shocked by the sudden appearance of Angela Martin behind him. His reaction was so genuine down to the bleeped swear word he dropped. Was Rainn Wilson not expecting Angela to show up or was this a scripted moment? So this moment was totally found on the day. It's not in the shooting draft. BJ shared in the commentary that they pitched it to rain and he was reluctant to do it because
he thought it might seem too broad. But then they were like, let's just give it a try. Just give it a try. And then I remember they told me to get as close to like Rainn's like arm, like just to sort of be way down there by his elbow. And so I was trailing him really closely. And when he turned around, I was right there and it just worked. And we all started laughing.
We knew we had to do it again. It's so lurky, lurk much. Well, well, back over at the pool tables, Michael's going to try to tie a cherry stem with his tongue. But instead he starts choking. Jenna, this scene was even bigger in the shooting draft. Not only does he choke, but then he starts dribbling cherry juice down his shirt. So gross.
And then he turns to Julie and says, you want to maybe hit a hot tub after this? Oh my gosh. So in this scene, he is kind of like spinning the pool cue around. We had a fan catch from Dandy Y in Canada who says, fakey pool cue at 12 minutes, 13 seconds. When Michael is spinning the pool cue, you can see it bending. What was it actually made of? Oh, good catch.
Such a good catch. You really can't see it. It is 100% a rubber pool cue. It is so bendy. It's almost ridiculous. I can't believe it made it in. Well, there was an alternate Michael talking head. It was in the shooting draft candy bag.
It made me laugh. Michael says, I've been dating for over 30 years. I think I know what I'm doing. Oh no. Well, Isabel and Dwight are playing whack-a-mole and Dwight is really good at it. And Isabel's like, oh my gosh, you're so good at it. And then Angela tries to join in, the lurker, and she says, this looks like a hoot. And you guys, it just made me think of my journal entry, Sam.
This looks like a hoot. I think I got tooted. You hit these balls with a large stick. Yes, exactly. I want to know how Angela Kinsey would write in her journal about her first whack-a-mole game. Please, can we have that? We need it.
It would go something like this. There was this really interesting machine. Our little tiny animals came out and they wanted me to hit them and I said, I will not. And then I had a cosmopolitan. XOXO. And then I would probably finish my journal entry with, I'll fill you in next time on what happened when I tried Ski Ball. XOXO, hugs.
I love how your journal entries, and this is true about your journal entries, they end with like a cliffhanger. Yes. Next time, I'm going to give you some details on this other thing. Yeah, they all end up like the gossip girl ones. I know. And then I also like write in my journal, like I'll say things like, oh, sorry to bore you, I've gone on and on.
Who's reading this? Who am I writing to? I can't believe I talked that long about whack-a-mole. My bad. Oh my gosh. Could you do a young adult book series that is just your journals? Please no. That would be so weird.
I really like this character. Well, Angela's whack-a-mole is not going to go well. And Dwight pulls her side and says, you know what? We had a good run, but I want a big family, like a big, big family, and she doesn't need to worry about their contract anymore, dissolved. He tries to break their contract. How many pieces of identification did they have on that table when they were making this contract?
So many signatures and stamps. How dare he? Truly. Mm-hmm. Oh, she's not going to take it well. Meanwhile, Michael is on top of a pool table. I don't know what he's doing. He's playing like air guitar on his pool stick.
I mean, it's going to get the attention of the manager. Yeah, she's like, do you want to pay 400 bucks to refelt this table? And Michael says, yeah, why don't you send the bill to 23? I don't care, Lane, Scranton, Pennsylvania. What is happening? He's going to get his ass kicked out. Yeah. I think the rosé is hitting us.
Maybe. Maybe. I just want to do the whole rest of the episode as your journal, frankly. It delights me so much. Guest Star Alert, our manager, Donna, was played by Amy Peetz. She was on the NBC sitcom, Caroline in the City, for which she was nominated for a Screen Actors Guild Award for Outstanding Performance by a Female Actor in a Comedy Series. She's also had recurring roles on Modern Family, Animal Kingdom, and she appears in five episodes
of The Office. She was also in a really good episode of Law and Order SVU, which I just watched the other day. Which one? It's the one where she plays Mama Zoe. She's really good in it. It's a good episode. During this scene, Pam and Jim are kind of trying to get Michael to calm down, and Pam
wants to continue the pool game. I have another improv brag. Do it. I improvised the line, you guys are stripes, I think. My scripted line was, I think she handled it pretty well, but instead I said, you guys are stripes, I think. And you know why you said that? Because I know about pool.
Because you're a pool shark. Yeah, I am. And I know that one person is stripes and one is solid. I know that. Sounds like one of my journal entries. You know what I want to find? What? I've got to have a journal entry about my plans to become a pool shark hustler.
Please. I must have one somewhere. Please. My journal. Surely. Surely. Michael is going to approach the manager and demand an apology. I loved their back and forth.
I loved it when he said the way he likes to be a manager has a dash of razzle-dazzle. I was so curious if that was scripted or if Steve like threw that out there. I went to the shooting draft. It's in the script. A dash of razzle-dazzle. I love it. Donna clearly has the thing that Jan had, which is that she's attracted to tragedy. Because she is sort of immediately smitten by Michael.
Just like, what is this thing in front of me? Yeah. It's like the first time you see a kitten or something or a puppy. You're like, what is this creature? I'm sort of drawn to it. They have a repartee. They do. In their repartee, we find out that Michael has written a whole book in his head.
It's called Somehow I Manage. The book cover is him with his sleeves rolled up shrugging. The manager says, have you read Lea Iacocca's classic book? And Michael says, read it. I own it. He hasn't read it. But no, I haven't read it. We had a fan question from Letty P. in Long Beach, California.
This is the second time Lea Iacocca's biography is mentioned on The Office. I've watched this show so many times, and it's made me curious to actually pick up the book. And it's so good. But why is it referred to so much when Michael hasn't even read it? Well, Letty, I'll tell you, it's because BJ Novak's dad co-authored that book. So this was a nod from BJ to his dad. This was a BJ Easter egg for his dad.
So cute. We really did that a lot on the show, like naming Pam and Jim's baby Cece and Sid and Dexter's and throwing the book in. We like to do that sort of thing. Andy and Aaron are still trying to hide their relationship because Andy does not want the drama. He doesn't. Don't want the drama.
So he's like, you know what, let's throw everyone off because a few people have made little comments that he thinks is about him and Aaron. He's like, I'm going to go talk to that girl. You go talk to that guy. Aaron is going to sit next to a man. She's going to rub her hand on his thigh and say, hey, big boy, do you like it when I do that? And Andy spits out his drink and is like, what are you doing?
Well, the guy that Aaron is talking to was played by our very own locations manager, Kyle Alexander. They shared in the commentary that Kyle just has such a friendly demeanor that he wouldn't seem threatening in any way. And probably nice for Ellie because he was someone that we all worked with. Totally. Andy kind of pulls Aaron aside, pulls her into this photo booth. And while they're in there, the camera is going off.
While they're arguing. Yes. Matt said that getting this photo strip right was really important to him. On the first day of this shoot week, Ed and Ellie got together with Michael Gallenberg, our production designer, and he took photos of them, which Matt went over and he created the photo strip that would be used in this scene. Yeah. And without this on the commentary, how important the story of the photo strip was to him?
Well, he also sent in an audio clip. Let's give it a listen. I also spent a lot of time working on the photos from the photo booth of Andy and Aaron. They tell a very sad story about their relationship. If you notice them, they each show a different stage of their relationship, ending with Aaron sad and by herself. You know, when Andy looks at these photos, he realizes this isn't the relationship that he wants.
嗯，他还发来了一段音频片段。我们来听听。我也花了很长时间制作安迪和艾伦在大头贴亭拍的照片。它们讲述了一个关于他们关系的非常悲伤的故事。如果你注意到它们，它们展示了他们关系的每个阶段，最后以艾伦伤心独处告终。你知道，当安迪看着这些照片时，他意识到这不是他想要的感情。
And he goes to the microphone to announce to everyone that he and Aaron are a dating. They are a couple. And it's a nice ending to their story. Sometimes those little props, designing those just right, really are important. And after Matt said that, I went and I paused on the strip. Same. Really good. And it's something I missed the first time I watched it.
然后他走到麦克风前向大家宣布他和艾伦在约会。他们是一对。这是他们故事的一个美好结局。有时候那些小道具，把它们设计得恰到好处，真的很重要。马特说完后，我去暂停了胶卷条。我也是。真的很好。这是我第一次看时漏掉的细节。
And it's just one of those things in this rewatch, it's so fun to discover. You know, I love a photo strip. I will go into any mall kiosk photo booth. Lady, it's the cover of our book is a photo strip that I saved for 18 years. Yeah. That you insisted that we do. I know. I tried to do the cough at our age thing.
这也是这次重温中发现的有趣事情之一。你知道的，我很喜欢大头贴。我会去任何商场自助亭拍照。天哪，我们书的封面就是我保存了18年的大头贴。是的，你坚持让我们拍的。我知道。我试图在我们这个年纪假装咳嗽。
It didn't work. You know, where you say like, like where you cough something that you, you kind of want people to hear. Mm-hmm. Like, like, you know what I mean? I do. Okay. Where are we?
没用。你知道的，就是那种，你故意咳嗽一声，希望别人听到。嗯。就像，你知道我的意思吗？我知道。好吧。我们在哪？
Oh, Matt has not shown up. Oscar's been sitting with the warehouse guys forever. I know. And Daryl is like, listen, I know he's super cute, but the truth is he's kind of a dumb dumb. Oscar. Yeah. He's like, you guys aren't a good match.
哦，马特还没出现。奥斯卡和仓库的伙计们坐了好久。我知道。达里尔就说，听着，我知道他超级可爱，但事实是他有点小笨蛋。奥斯卡。是啊。他说，你们俩不合适。
No. Daryl's trying. He's trying to look out for Oscar in this moment. In college, I dated just this real dumb dumb. Hello, Rose. Oh, good looking. Settle in, Rose. What do you got for me?
不。达里尔在努力。他这个时候在为奥斯卡着想。上大学时，我交往过一个真正的大笨蛋。你好，露丝。哦，长得真好看。坐下吧，露丝。你有什么要告诉我的？
Nothing. Just that, like, it was so clear to me. He was just super hot. I candy. Mm-hmm. And I don't know. It didn't last long. Was it fun?
没什么。只是，那对我来说太明显了。他就是超级辣。养眼。嗯。而且我不知道。没持续多久。好玩吗？
Not really. Oh. Well, that's a bummer. But I loved looking at him. He's so beautiful. So I get it, Oscar. What's your journal entry? I looked at this guy for a while today.
不太好。哦。那真遗憾。但我喜欢看着他。他太帅了。所以我理解你，奥斯卡。你的日记写了什么？我今天看这个家伙看了好一会儿。
But guess what? Just as maybe Oscar is considering that they aren't a match, Matt walks in. Oscar's delighted. He walks in. He wants to go play basketball. Oscar's like, yeah. The two of them shooting next to each other was so funny. It was actually a note in the shooting draft that Oscar tries to shoot and it, like, ricochets
但你猜怎么着？就在奥斯卡可能认为他们不合适的时候，马特走进来了。奥斯卡很高兴。他走进来。他想去打篮球。奥斯卡说，行啊。他们两个互相投篮的场景太搞笑了。拍摄剧本里其实有一条备注，说奥斯卡尝试投篮结果球反弹了
off the, like, backboard and, like, he's chasing it on the ground. I want to say it is very hard to be bad at things like that when you have to as an actor. Like that was some really good, bad basketball acting on Oscar's part. Yeah. He actually can, like, shoot pretty well. Right. I remember that from the basketball episode when all those guys started shooting. Yeah.
撞到篮板上，然后他在地上追着球跑。我想说，作为一个演员，当你必须表现得很烂时，要做到这一点真的很难。奥斯卡那段打篮球的演技真的很棒。对。他其实挺会投篮的。没错。我记得篮球那集里所有那些家伙开始投篮的时候。对。
I'm going to wrap up a couple of storylines here. We're getting near the end of the episode. Andy's going to get on a loud speaker, announces that he's been on a few successful dates with Erin. There'll probably be more. No one cares. No. No one even looks over.
我来总结一下这里的几个剧情线。我们快到这集的尾声了。安迪要用扩音器广播，宣布他跟艾琳约会了几次很成功。可能还会有。没人关心。不。甚至没人抬头看一眼。
Mm-mm. No. Andy and Erin are so happy, though. Erin especially. Dwight and Isabel are leaving together when Angela approaches them. Still lurking. I don't think she was lurking. This was, like, a, like, full frontal approach.
嗯嗯。没有。不过安迪和艾琳很开心。尤其是艾琳。德怀特和伊莎贝尔正要一起离开，这时安吉拉走近他们。还在潜伏。我不认为她在潜伏。这是一次正面接近。
I know, but lurking in the sense that everywhere these people turn, you're on top of them. You're all over them. But you know what? Rightfully so. He should not have broken that contract. I like Angela in this moment. Well, she's going to serve him papers to appear in court. That's right.
我知道，但潜伏的意思是，这些人无论转向哪里，你都缠着他们。你无处不在。但你知道吗？理所当然。他不应该违反那份合同。我喜欢这个时候的安吉拉。好吧，她要去给她送传票让她出庭。没错。
For breach of contract. Mm-hmm. Isabel wax her on the forehead. We had a fan question from Stacey C. and Charlotte, North Carolina. Angela, did she really smack you on the head? She did. That was real. It was scripted.
因为违约。嗯嗯。伊莎贝尔拍了拍她的额头。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的粉丝斯黛西·C的提问。安吉拉，她真的打你的头了吗？是的。那是真的。剧本里写了。
I want you to know that when this episode aired, people took to the message boards sympathizing for Angela. This never happened for my character. I did not like that she hit you on the head. I didn't like it. You didn't like it. And guess who else didn't like it? Who?
我想让你们知道，当这集播出时，人们纷纷在留言板上为安吉拉鸣不平。我的角色从来没有这种待遇。我可不喜欢她打你的头。我也不喜欢。你也不喜欢。你猜还有谁不喜欢？谁？
Birdie Kinsey. My mom. She did not care for it. No. Well, Angela is not going to be deterred. She scurries off, but Dwight will be hearing from her in court. I mean, several people are brought together in this episode. Birdie Aaron, Isabel and Dwight, and Michael.
伯蒂·金西。我妈妈。她可不在乎。好吧，安吉拉是不会罢休的。她溜走了，但德怀特会在法庭上收到她的传票。我是说，这集里好几对都被凑到了一起。伯蒂和艾伦、伊莎贝尔和德怀特，还有迈克尔。
He's got a date. Date Mike actually came through. I mean, kind of. He wasn't being date Mike. He was just being like righteous Michael at the bar. Well, he thinks it worked once again. This episode ends with just an amazing tag, amazing. It's one of my favorite of the whole series.
他有个约会。约会迈克尔真的成功了。我是说，某种程度上。他不是在当约会迈克尔。他只是在酒吧里表现得像个正义的迈克尔。好吧，他认为这又成功了。这一集的结尾是一个非常棒的彩蛋，太棒了。这是我整部剧中最喜欢的彩蛋之一。
Agree. It is Darryl and Hide from the warehouse, and Darryl encourages Hide to tell his story, his origin story. Yeah. Earlier in the episode, he sort of teases it to Oscar. He's like, have you heard Hide's story? I mean, it's fascinating. It's amazing.
同意。是达里尔和仓库的英二，达里尔鼓励英二讲他的故事，他的身世背景。对。这集前面，他已经在奥斯卡面前稍微卖了个关子。他说，你听过英二的故事吗？我的意思是，太迷人了。太惊人了。
Yeah. And here it is. He tells his story. He says in Japan, he was the top heart surgeon, but he made a mistake while operating on a Yakuza boss who died as a result, so Hide ran away to escape the wrath of the Yakuza, came to America on a fishing boat with no food, no money. Darryl gave him a job. Now he has an American car, a job, a woman.
对。就是现在。他讲了他的故事。他说在日本，他是顶级心脏外科医生，但他给一个极道老大做手术时犯了错，导致老大死了，所以英二为了逃避极道的追杀逃跑了，坐着一艘没有食物、没有钱的渔船来到美国。达里尔给了他一份工作。现在他有一辆美国车、一份工作、一个女人。
Darryl saved his life, but he has a secret twist. He killed the Yakuza boss on purpose. He's a really good surgeon. The best. It's so good. It's so good. Let's look into Hide's DMs. Hide, if you hear this, check your DMs.
达里尔救了他的命，但他有一个秘密反转。他是故意杀死极道老大的。他是个非常出色的外科医生。最棒的。太棒了。太棒了。让我们去私信英二。英二，如果你听到这个，查收你的私信。
We would love to talk to you about your experience on the office and this talking head. You just crushed it. We just think you're awesome. Hide had been on the show for a long time as one of the warehouse workers. And BJ said in an interview that getting this tag into the show was a mission of his. He said that he loved the idea that this character, who we've only seen in the background, had a life story infinitely more dramatic than anyone else the documentary crew had been following, but they never thought to ask.
我们很想和你聊聊你在《办公室》的经历以及这段独白。你演得太绝了。我们觉得你太棒了。英二作为仓库工人之一在剧里演了很长时间。BJ在一次采访中说，把这个彩蛋放进剧里是他的一个使命。他说他很喜欢这样一个想法：这个我们只在背景里看到过的角色，有着比纪录片摄制组关注的任何人都更具戏剧性的人生故事，但他们从没想到去问问。
BJ also said that they shot six different versions of this in various places. They shot Hide by himself in the warehouse, Hide by himself in the bar. They shot Darryl and Hide in the warehouse, Darryl and Hide in the bar. And we also shot two totally different backstories. Well, I love that they chose the one with Darryl standing next to him. Me too. I thought it was really just perfect. I went to the candy bag in the shooting draft for this talking head and BJ is right, there
BJ还说，他们在不同地方拍摄了六个不同的版本。他们拍了英二独自在仓库，英二独自在酒吧。他们拍了达里尔和英二在仓库，达里尔和英二在酒吧。我们还拍了两个完全不同的背景故事。好吧，我很高兴他们选择了达里尔站在他旁边的那一个。我也是。我觉得真的是完美。我查看了这段独白的拍摄剧本，BJ是对的，
were many versions. I'm going to share with you two of my favorites. Okay. In one, Hide's brother had put a hit out on him and Hide was traveling the world hiding. That's the one that was in the shooting draft. I remember that one from the table read. Yes. In the other one, Hide was a sumo champion and he traveled to India and then drank some
有很多版本。我跟你们分享两个我最喜欢的。好吧。其中一个版本是英二的哥哥对下了追杀令，英二在世界各地东躲西藏。这就是拍摄剧本里的版本。我从剧本朗读会上还记得那个。是的。在另一个版本中，英二是一名相扑冠军，他去了印度，然后喝了一些
kind of tea there that made him not hungry and not want to eat and he lost a bunch of weight and his wife left him and he was penniless and he came to America. Well I loved this one. I loved this one and BJ shared on the commentary when Hide says American car that Hide improvised that. Yes. And BJ loved that. Well that was happy hour guys, we're going to miss you while we're on our vacation.
那里的某种茶，让他不饿，不想吃东西，结果瘦了一大圈，妻子也离开了他，他身无分文来到了美国。嗯，我很喜欢这个。我很喜欢这个，BJ在评论音轨里分享说，当英二说“美国车”时，那是英二即兴发挥的。是的。BJ很喜欢那个。好吧，这就是当天的欢乐时光，伙计们，我们度假期间会想念你们的。
We love you. But like I said, we will be back July 15th for secretary's day with Miss Ellie Kemper. We just want to say thank you to Matt Stone for his audio clips and of course Randy Cordray who always gives us the behind the scenes details and we hope this week you guys have a little bit of razzle dazzle and a great week. Love you. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我们爱你们。但就像我说的，我们将在7月15日回归，带来秘书节特辑，嘉宾是埃莉·肯珀女士。我们要感谢马特·石头发来的音频剪辑，当然还有总是为我们提供幕后细节的兰迪·科德雷，希望本周你们能有一点点魔幻魅力，度过美好的一周。爱你们。拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com for a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是雷德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com，使用优惠码Office即可免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。